so my name is Alena peasanty I was a
usual fellows 18 graduate student I was
working with Anjali at an independent
study for farmers economy and the usage
of Technology
so there is an ever-increasing need to
invest in agriculture and one of the
biggest challenge for that is the credit
access for affordable loans for farmers
and we have been discussing with Angela
about how we can use technology to solve
decision and what is the design of this
technology that we can use for farmers
that they can have better access to
credit but not only that how we can help
the lenders to access those farmers
which are mostly in remote areas and
they lack data so we have been working
with Anjali on thinking on this in these
these problems and also restructuring
the right questions that we should think
about to find us the proper solutions we
thought it was moral design thinking and
design of thinking about the process and
how is the clients and how are the the
the not the clients but the farmers in
the lenders perspective with their
lenses so what are they they main
questions that they do while they are in
the credit process right and what are
they start to squat today what are the
failures of the status quo and where we
find the technologies that have a
compelling user case to deliver
solutions for lack of data and
connection between farmers and lenders
so it was very a systematic approach
that we have been noting and how we
think of all those technologies and
innovation and deploy discharge to this
to this problem
so I manage my time with weekly meetings
with Anjali for a period of time we set
up very narrowed deliverables and during
that process we were iterating with some
of the professors and some of the the
resources that I needed and I took that
the discipline so having that in my
schedule so we could deliver and have
credible fruitful discussions every
meeting that we we had together
and what I learned in this process with
her is was how to we systematically
think or how we make we make the right
questions and from the right questions
we started to find the solutions which
derives to the right questions and where
do we find the resources and it's a
system dynamic way of doing a
formulating your New York problem
statement which was very helpful for me
on in the industry so in the projects
Angele was super relevant to help us to
think okay to solve this for this
challenge we need an expert in different
areas who are the experts and she
connected us with the those experts that
eventually came up and helped us to
contribute in also she connected us with
many entrepreneurs and also companies
outside the scope of MIT for example she
connected us with a guy from India from
one of the largest solar panel companies
who also in certain says assist you in
contact with us on thinking about
contribution with data center who also
will contribute with our research
I think they that that's the environment
that MIT brings to you it's quite unique
right this possibility that helped us to
connect with people from different
backgrounds not only that they are the
experts in the in the background in the
world they're most renewable faculty
members scientists they will add your
different perspective if there is this
ocean of a think of different ideas
different perspectives that helps you to
build up your own this is something that
was is unique at MIT also the capacity
of the connection right because the
world expands to you and they opens
because you're an at MIT so there is
nothing equal like that at all we in any
other place
I all the other feedbacks that I was
integrating through the connections that
we establish through the process in this
course were quite valuable actually
every feedback every iteration shape it
somehow the process of what we are doing
now and that's the valuable thing of of
this course right is also to have the
possibility to hear other opinions not
only if you stay on your own path you're
blind to what is new or outside and that
prevents us somehow to make innovation
which is not the case here
it's you've seen so many different
things sometimes that you never fought
before and that changes and that
improves what you are doing
I guess the biggest challenge for in
this process was still having the
discipline to find a proper the having
discipline in this structure to find the
solutions because our are so many
elements because you learn how to think
and sing the whole world and to try to
grasp the answers and in a systematic
and organized way was for me and
challenging the beginning but I learned
how to navigate that eventually later
so it's an hour it's an interesting
process that you learn it how to deal
with so many variables and make the in
making the puzzles to deliver to you a
whole a clear and transparent picture
well this project won it there is such
two branches of that one is a start-up
that I'm doing which we already are
creating the FinTech which is exclusive
dedicated to the agriculture market
which it's the first in its in the
market where we use data analytics and
we designer the process in this course
to improve and deliver better financial
solutions to both lenders and farmers so
we allow them to have affordable loans
and on top of that there is also because
this is so unique and so new in the
world we are doing a research with
Angela and other professors of senior
faculty members at MIT with support from
the data center as well - he studied the
economic behavior of farmers and lenders
with more data this data will help to
solve for the problems of sustainable
financier and economy a conclusion we
don't know so that's one of the
investigations that we are doing that's
one of the next challenge and again some
of the answers for that we are trying to
find with the for this question